So congratulations, you have now mastered a
basic survival course for NP-completeness.
You have learned about advanced algorithmic techniques
such as intelligent search trees, pre-processing,
and other advanced techniques such as fixed-parameter tractability
that will help you solve and P-complete problems in practice.
Now this material is very deep.
Not many people, at least in my experience,
even understand with NP-completeness means,
but even fewer people know about these tools and techniques
that you can use to poke holes or find loopholes
in the laws of NP-completeness.
So knowing these techniques and possibly learning more about them
can really make you stand out
whenever NP-complete problems need to be solved.
Of course, even though these techniques are very powerful,
sometimes it's just not possible in practice to solve an NP-complete problem.
As I hope you're expecting by now,
we still won't give up.
Rather, in the next unit,
we will see if it helps us when we relax a little bit,
and instead of looking for the best possible solution,
are content with solutions that are not quite optimal.
In other words, next time we'll get sloppy.